Abby can you make this can of tuna a
little less I feel ya tuna salad
s are boring
okay don't come at me I know it's a
quesadilla can of tuna damn gonna add a
big pumpkin scoop of guacamole a little
bit of mayo so you guys know how
it does help though a little bit of
barbecue sauce
got some corn and bell peppers
and a load of cheese now we mix her all
together
a little bit of olive oil all right we
got a whole grain tortilla here I'm
gonna load it up with our filling
now we get our crispy
we got lots of fiber rich carbs in our
tortilla plus we've got fiber in our
vegetables and our guacamole protein in
our can of tuna plus lots of healthy
fats in the guac wow it looks really
good thanks for making that for me oh
yeah